hi everyone
this is professor m science and today i
want to talk about
erin fess's theorem in another one of
our videos on rigorous quantum mechanics
the general idea we'll explore today
is the time evolution of the expectation
value
of operators air infest theorem is
simply a special case of this general
situation
where the operators are the position of
a particle or the momentum of a particle
what we'll find
is that the time evolution of the
expectation values of position
and momentum is described by a set of
equations that resemble those obeyed by
a classical particle as such
erenfe's theorem allows us to make a
direct connection
between the classical and the quantum
worlds let's go
our starting point are expectation
values
the necessary ingredients are the state
of the system psi
and some observable a the expectation
value of a
in state psi is then written like this
and is equal to the brass i the operator
a
and the ket psi if we're only
calculating the expectation value of the
same state psi
and there's no possible confusion then
we'll emit this subscript here
and we'll simply write the expectation
value of a in state psi
like this now the expectation value
is a number that describes the average
of the probability distribution of state
psi
when written in the basis spanned by the
eigenstates of operator a
for a full refresh about expectation
values i encourage you to check out the
corresponding video linked in the
description
and what we want to do today is to
consider the time dependence of
expectation values
to do so we write the state psi again
which in general depends on time t
as given by the schrollinger equation
the observable a
may also in general depend on time
now many familiar observables like
position momentum or angular momentum do
not depend on time
but we can sometimes encounter
observables that do depend on time
and an example would be a hamiltonian
with a time-dependent external potential
say a varying external electric field
if we now calculate the expectation
value of a in state psi
then it will also depend on time
and is given by the usual expression
just to be absolutely clear the
expectation value is a scalar
and what this is showing is that its
value is a function of time
the time evolution comes from both the
bra and the cat
whose time dependent is in turn
determined by the schrodinger equation
and if the operator also depends on time
then it will also contribute to the time
dependence of the expectation value
we now want to consider the time
evolution of the expectation value
so we start by calculating its time
derivative
we can explicitly write the expression
for the expectation value in terms of
the state psi
and the observable a
and we can now apply the chain rule to
get three terms
the first involves the derivative of the
bra
the second involves the derivative of
the cat
and the third involves the derivative of
the observable
at the side point before we move on note
i have omitted the dependence of the
operator a on time
so the expressions could actually fit in
the line
to make progress we now write the
schrodinger equation which tells us
about the time evolution of the ket
and we're also going to need the drawing
equation in the joule space to obtain
the time derivative of the bra
remember that in going to the joule
space cats become brass here
and here scalars become their complex
conjugates hence the minus sign here
and in principle operators become their
adjoints but the hamiltonian is a
hermitian operator so we can write it
here directly without the adjoint
we're now ready to complete the
calculation of the time derivative of
the expectation value
we first take this expression for the
time derivative of the bra
and insert it here doing so we get this
first term
we can also take this expression for the
time derivative of the ket
and insert it here and doing so we get
this second term
and we finally have the third term which
doesn't change
the first two terms only differ by this
minus sign here
and by the fact that the product of the
hamiltonian with the operator a appears
in the order h
a here and in the opposite order a h
here this means that we can combine the
first two terms to this expression
involving the commutator
of a with h and we still have the same
final term
both terms now look like expectation
values so we can write the time
derivative of the expectation value of
a as equal to 1 over i h bar
times the expectation value of the
commutator of a with h
plus the expectation value of the time
derivative of a
this expression is one of the key
results of today's video
it is a general result that applies to
any observable a
however today we'll focus on the special
case when the operator a
is either the position or the momentum
operator
in this special case the resulting
equations are called erin fest's theorem
but the general expression appears in
many other quantum problems
and for another example you can check
out the video on constants of motion
linked in the description
for erin fest's theorem we'll want to
use this expression for the position and
the momentum operators
the first thing to note is that position
and momentum
are both time time-independent
observables
this means that the second term here
will vanish and we only need to consider
the first term
which critically includes the commutator
with the hamiltonian
this means that we need to decide on
what the hamiltonian of the system is
for simplicity we'll consider a particle
moving in a scalar potential
so that we can write the hamiltonian as
the sum of the kinetic energy
plus a general scalar potential
let's start with position using the
formula for the time dependence of the
expectation value
we get 1 over ih bar times the
expectation value of the commutator
now before we move on i should clarify
that i'm abusing notation somewhat in
this expression
the position operator r is really made
up of three separate operators
x y and z
this means that this expression really
corresponds to three separate equations
one for each component for example the
equation for the position operator in
the x direction
looks like this
and we have analogous equation for the y
and z components
this compact form up here using the
operator r is very convenient
but whenever i use it in the rest of the
video you need to remember that it is
simply a shorthand
moving on we first get the pre-factor
and now we separate the hamiltonian into
its kinetic energy part
and its potential energy part
the next step is to realize that this
commutator vanishes
because r commutes with any function of
position
you can find the full proof of this
result in the video and functions of
operators linked in the description
but in short it is a consequence of the
fact that any function of r is simply
given by a power series in r
and r commutes with any power of itself
this means that the only commutator we
have to evaluate is the first one here
involving the kinetic energy to see what
it is let's consider the commutator
between
x and p squared you can expand p
squared in terms of its components
x commutes with p y and pz so we can
remove these two terms
and we end up with this commutator at
this point we need to remember the
general formula for the commutator of an
operator
a with the product bc of another two
operators
this can be spelled out as this first
term
plus this second term
if you don't remember this relation you
can find the proof in our video on
commutator algebra
but moving on we can then use this
relation for our commutator up here
to get this first term and the second
term
this here is the canonical commutation
relation
and so is this so we end up with 2
ihbar px
doing the same for the commutators of y
and z we would find analogous
expressions
so using the compact vector notation we
can conclude that the commutator of
r with the kinetic energy term is equal
to i h bar
over m times p
going back to the time derivative of the
expectation value of the position
operator
we find that it's equal to 1 over m
times the expectation value of the
momentum operator
and this is it this is the erin fest
equation for position
now looking at it it looks suspiciously
familiar
but let's keep going for now and we'll
come back to this later
let's now turn to momentum the
derivation is very similar to the one
for position
so i won't go into as much detail as we
did for position
using the formula for the time dependent
of the expectation value
we get one over i h bar times the
expectation value of the commutator
again this is just a shorthand for three
separate equations one for each of the
components of the momentum operator
we can again expand the hamiltonian to
get the expectation value of these two
terms
and the momentum operator commutes with
any power of itself so this commutator
vanishes
this means that the only commutator we
have to evaluate is the second one here
and to do so we need to remember result
from the video on functions of operators
the commutator between the momentum
operator and
any function f of the position operator
is equal to minus i h bar times the
derivative of the function
f we're just going to use this and if
you cannot remember this property right
now you can find the link to the video
on functions of operators in the
description
the same is true for the other momentum
and position components
so in our case this means that the
commutator between p
and the potential v is equal to minus i
h bar
times the gradient of the potential
going back to the time derivative of the
expectation value of the momentum
operator
we find that it's equal to minus the
expectation value
of the gradient of the potential and
this is it
this is the iron fest equation for the
momentum
again it probably looks pretty familiar
but before we discuss why let's
summarize the theorem
erinfest's theorem says that the time
derivative of the expectation value of
position
is equal to 1 over m times the
expectation value of momentum
and that the time derivative of the
expectation value of momentum
is equal to minus the expectation value
of the gradient of the potential
we can actually combine these two
equations into a single expression
we can write m times the second time
derivative of the expectation value of
the position operator
the next step is to separate the time
derivative
and using the first erin fest equation
we can insert it here
and we get this
we can cancel the mass terms here and
here
and what's left is simply the time
derivative of the expectation value of
the momentum
which is just the left hand side of the
second air inverse equation
so we can write this whole expression as
minus the expectation value of the
gradient of the potential
this means that we can rewrite the
theorem like this
and we're now ready to discuss why the
equations in ironfest theorem look so
familiar
the theorem provides a connection
between classical
and quantum mechanics to see this we can
consider newton's second law
it says that the mass times the
acceleration
is equal to the total force acting on
the system
if this force arises from a scalar
potential then it can be written as the
negative of the gradient of the
potential
and this equation now has the same form
as this equation
up here i don't know about you but i
find this analogy pretty exciting
it suggests that we may be able to
exploit air infest theorem
to make a connection between quantum and
classical particles
the logical next question becomes how do
we make that connection
can we really use newtonian mechanics to
describe the motion
of quantum particles
to explore this question let's describe
the state of our system in the position
representation this essentially means
describing the system in terms of wave
functions
so let's consider a wave function psi of
r and t
to make the discussion concrete we're
going to assume that the wave function
describes a wave packet
pictorially i can draw a single spatial
axis
say the x-axis and then the wave packet
at a particular time
t 0 will be something like this
describe by the wave function at time t
at 0. later time t the wave packet may
have moved
say to this new position with the
corresponding wave function
this should look familiar but for a full
refresh on wave packets you can check
out the corresponding video linked in
the description
in this context the expectation value of
the position operator describes the
center of the wave packet
at time t0 it is at this position
and at time t it is at this position
this means that the expectation value is
a point in space
and this point traces a trajectory as a
function of time
now the true wave function cannot be
described by a single point it has an
extension
that can be characterized by the root
mean square deviation delta x
for the initial wave packet it should be
something like this
and for the second something like this
and we know that this extended nature of
the wave function is essential to fully
describe a quantum particle
however erinfest's theorem says that the
mass times the second derivative of the
expectation value of the position
operator
is equal to the negative of the
expectation value of the gradient
and we've already discussed that this
equation has a very similar form to
newton's second law of motion
this expectation value here is simply
the center of the wave packet here
or here so at this point we may be
tempted to ask
does the center of the wave packet obey
the laws of classical mechanics
the answer is not quite
in the quantum case we can use erinfest
theorem to write an equation relating
the change in the center of the wave
packet
to the expectation value of the gradient
of the potential
in the classical case we can write
newton's second law
where we can also rewrite the force as
proportional to the gradient of a
potential
if we now replace the position of the
classical particle
with the position of the center of mass
of the wave packet
then the center of mass will behave like
a classical particle
if the gradient of the classical
potential is evaluated at the position
of the center of the wave packet
this means that the center of the wave
packet of the quantum particle
will move like a classical particle if
the expectation value of the gradient of
the potential
is equal to the gradient of the
potential evaluated at the expectation
value
of the position if this equality
holds then the center of the wave packet
will move like a classical point
particle
if this equality doesn't hold then the
center of the wave packet despite
behaving like a point particle
will not obey the laws of classical
physics
so now the question becomes does this
equality hold
the answer is not straightforward let's
consider just one dimension for
simplicity but the discussion can be
trivially generalized to three
dimensions
the potential energy is a function of
position
and when working with operators we
describe functions through their power
series
so we'll need to consider the power
series of the potential v
the key quantity that features in the
erin fest equations is the gradient of
the potential
which in one dimension is simply the
derivative of the potential
which in turn is given by this power
series
we can now use this power series to
spell out this equation up here
starting with the left hand side we have
the expectation value of the gradient
which is equal to the sum of the
expectation values of the various powers
by contrast for the right hand side we
have the gradient of the potential
evaluated at the expectation value of
the position
which is equal to the sum of the powers
of the expectation values
these two expressions will be equal if
the expectation value of the powers
is equal to the corresponding powers of
the expectation values
but is this equality true we actually
have two possibilities
for n smaller than or equal to 2
then this equality holds
it is very easy to check this result as
an example we can consider the case n
equals 2
which gives this
by contrast when n is larger than 2
then the equality does not hold in
general
again you can check this result easily
and as an example we can consider the
case
n equals 3 which gives this
this means that in general the
expectation value of the gradient of the
potential
is not equal to the gradient of the
potential evaluated at the expectation
value of the position operator
and in turn this means that the point
particle associated with the center of
the wave packet
does not follow the rules of classical
mechanics
now this result will come as somewhat
disappointing because we were hoping to
make a connection between classical
and quantum mechanics however there is
still some hope
we saw that if n is smaller than or
equal to 2
then the expectation value of x to the
power n minus 1
is equal to the corresponding power of
the expectation value
this means that the center of the wave
packet thus behave as a classical
particle
if the potential can be written with
powers up to second order
now this subset of potentials actually
includes a number of very important
situations
for n equals 0 the potential is constant
and we have a free particle for n equals
1
the potential is linear and we have a
particle moving in a uniform force field
that could for example be an external
electric field
and for n equals 2 the potential is
quadratic
and we have a harmonic oscillator in all
these
cases the center of the wave packet does
move like a classical
point particle
and in fact there is more we can
consider what's called the
quasi-classical regime
by that we mean a situation in which the
difference between this term
and this term becomes negligible so that
we can actually approximate the motion
of the center of the wave packet with
the motion of a classical particle
this quadratic classical regime occurs
when the wave packet is sufficiently
localized
compared to other relevant length scales
to see this pictorially let's consider
the x-axis again
and let's imagine that the wave packet
at time t
is rather narrow we have its center here
and its width here mathematically and in
the full 3d version
we have a wave packet that only takes
sizable values within delta r
and pretty much vanishes outside of this
region
now i've drawn the wave packet to be
very narrow but what really matters is
that it's narrow compared to the other
relevant length scales of the problem
in particular the quasi-classical regime
describes a situation
when changes in the potential v occur
over length scales
much larger than those of the wave
packet width
so that the potential changes very
slowly over the length scale
of this diagram in this case we can
approximate the gradient of the
potential in this region
by its value at the center of the region
so this is the quasi-classical regime
the wave packet is very narrow compared
to the length scale over which the
potential changes
working in this regime we can now
evaluate the expectation value of the
gradient of the potential
and explicitly writing out the
expectation value in the position
representation we get this
can now use the fact that the potential
changes very slowly across the wave
packet as encoded by this expression
to approximate this gradient by its
value at the center of the wave packet
this means that this term now is a
constant so we can take it out of the
integral
and we end up with this term
times the remaining terms in the
integral
the integral is just the normalization
condition for the wave function
so we finally get the gradient evaluated
at the center of the wave packet
and this is it in the quasi-classical
regime the expectation value of the
gradient of the potential here
is approximately equal to the gradient
of the potential at the center
of the wave packet here and this means
that in the quasi-classical regime
the center of the wave packet behaves
pretty much like a classical particle
now this sounds great because we've
managed to make some sort of connection
between the classical
and the quantum behavior of particles
the question you'll probably have now is
whether this quasi-classical regime is
at all relevant
after all these conditions up here may
appear somewhat stringent
well it turns out that these conditions
are made by most macroscopic
objects so the quasi-classical regime is
very relevant
to very roughly estimate this we can
take the de broglie wavelength of a
macroscopic object
as giving the size of the wave packet
and for a microscopic object this is
tiny
much smaller than the distance over
which potentials vary so that the wave
packet can be made
narrow enough to satisfy the conditions
of the quasi-classical regime
this is it for today but i want to leave
you with this very important result
the quasi-classical limit applies to
most microscopic objects providing a
clear connection
between the quantum microscopic world
and the classical
macroscopic world airfest theorem
provides a means to relay the classical
and the quantum worlds however the time
evolution of expectation values goes
well beyond this to see another
application i encourage you to check out
the video on constant of motion and as
always
if you liked the video please subscribe